wohnen in der stadt inklusive hübscher
grünanlagen das bietet das neubaugebiet
während arena in schleswig die häuser
hier werden abgetrennt von schicken
hätten davor ein streifen rasen
und das allerbeste den heckenschnitt
gibt es auch noch gratis
denn das grün gehört der stadt und tinus
für die pflege ganz zu 300.000 euro im
jahr hinblättern
die planer wollten es so ohne worte
die stadt nachdenken müssen ich hätte
das ja an die eigentümer abgegeben weil
dann wahrscheinlich auch kein problem
damit gehabt das zu machen
ja super schöne verschwendung von
steuergeldern kann ich da nur sagen also
ist ja irgendwo nicht in ordnung leider
hat die stadt schließlich sicher die
größere baustellen und probleme obwohl
das geld sinnvoller investiert wäre als
in die hacken
die leitidee der planer das wohnen in
die landschaft einbetten
dabei bleiben die freiräume zwischen den
neuen häusern städtisches eigentum die
grundstücksgrenzen bilden die hätten sie
stehen auf öffentlichen grund jetzt kann
sich die stadt also stolzer eigentümer
von 9,4 kilometer hecken
ein weiterer grund für die hohen kosten
die hecken sind so angelegt dass der
schnitt größtenteils per hand erfolgen
muss auf der hausseite passen die
maschinen nicht durch hier ist es
einfach zu eng
im rathaus will man sich zum hacken
waren sind vor unserer kamera nicht
äußern
schriftlich heißt es die hätten pflanzen
sind als wichtige vom planungsbüro
entwickelte komponente zu verstehen die
der umsetzung des planerischen ziels
gehen es war gewollt anpflanzungen und
grünflächen nicht im privaten zu geben
und besonders absurd viele bewohner
haben zusätzlich auch noch ihre eigene
hecke gepflanzt also quasi hecke neben
hecke
das macht ja sinn
und übrigens von den kosten wusste die
stadt die schleswiger stadtwerke die mit
der hätten pflege beauftragt sind haben
frühzeitig von dieser schnapsidee
abgeraten
als umweltdienste haben wir seinerzeit
also vor beginn der baulichen
entwicklung der bauabschnitte auf die
hohen unterhaltungskosten hingewiesen
aber unser mann darauf wurde leider
nicht ernst genommen das verständnis für
diese luxus grünflächen hält sich auch
bei den bürgern ins schließlich in
grenzen
finde ich ein bisschen habe ich alles
also das müsste anders irgendwie
aufgeteilt werden ja also ich wohne auf
dem dorf und da schneidet zum beispiel
jeder seine hecke selbst nicht das ja da
stört mich schon
da störte nicht so viel geld das ist ja
auch mein geld was das geld verplempert
wird eine gärtner rechnung von rund
300.000 euro pro jahr
doch immerhin die stadt will eine solche
planung in zukunft nicht wiederholen 9,4
kilometer hacker sind wohl genug für den
ort